vamos a fijarnos en las conformaciones
del ciclo hexano de sustituido así que
vamos a empezar con una estructura de
puntos ok aquí vamos a tener nuestro
ciclohexano más o menos ahí está la
estructura de puntos y vamos a poner dos
grupos metilo digamos que estén
apuntando hacia nosotros verdad y
ponemos justamente nuestra cuña porque
ahí tenemos un
un grupo metilo que íbamos a poner otro
que esté también apuntando hacia
nosotros y ahí tenemos un ciclo hexano
que tiene un grupo metilo en el carbono
1 y en el carbono 2 ahora si nos fijamos
en cómo nombrar a esta a esta molécula
por supuesto digamos su nombre principal
sería ciclo hexano verdad pero tenemos
dos grupos metilo así que esto será 1/2
dimetil ciclo hexano pero no sólo eso
tenemos que estos dos grupos metilo
están justamente saltando hacia nosotros
así que de hecho están en el mismo lado
y si pensamos digamos en el plano del
anillo de carbono digamos aquí da este
tipo de formaciones les llamamos cis muy
bien entonces esto sería sis
1/2 dimetil ciclohexano y sis significa
que se encuentran justamente o bueno que
se encuentran del mismo lado así que
tenemos el cis 1/2 dimetil ciclohexano
en este caso estamos pensando que
justamente ambos están del mismo lado y
van hacia arriba así que vamos a poner
esos grupos metilo justamente en estas
con formaciones digamos en esta de aquí
entonces aquí tenemos nuestro carbono 1
y aquí tendríamos nuestro carbono 2 en
estos dos casos van hacia arriba verdad
entonces este es un grupo metilo axial
mientras que este es un grupo metilo
ecuatorial ahora sí si giramos un
poquito esto y digamos que llegamos
justamente a esta conformación entonces
éste corresponde al carbono 1 déjenme
déjenme ir los enumerando este es el 1
este es el 2 verdad entonces aquí
tenemos este grupo metilo y aquí tenemos
al otro grupo metilo ahora bien qué es
lo que ocurre cuando estamos ahora en la
conformación bote pues esencialmente
tenemos lo mismo verdad tenemos aquí
nuestro ch3
y nuestro otro ch3 esto es para el
carbono 1 y para el carbono 2 lo que
ocurre aquí es que vamos a arrastrar el
carbono 1 verdad hasta esta posición
digamos de abajo vamos a arrastrarlo a
una posición de abajo y ahora
corresponde este carbono uno sería el
carbono que sería el carbono que se
encuentra aquí verdad entonces aquí
tenemos el carbono 1 aquí tendríamos el
carbono 2 y este grupo metilo
corresponde ahora a este que tengo acá y
déjame ponerlo ahora ya con el mismo
color este sería este ese h3 verdad
sería ssh 3 mientras que
para este carbono 2 tendríamos aquí el
ch3 muy bien entonces simplemente ya
para llegar a nuestra otra conformación
bote tendríamos este de aquí serían
h3 y aquí tendríamos el
h3 de gm es exactamente este
h 3 para el carbono 1 y el carbono 2
respectivamente ahora si nos fijamos
para nuestra segunda conformación silla
el grupo metilo en el carbono 1 a 1 se
encuentra arriba verdad de hecho
empezamos con un carbono que se
encontraba arriba y ahora sigue estando
hacia arriba pero ahora se encuentra en
una posición ecuatorial verdad por otro
lado el carbono 2 empezaba en una
posición hacia arriba y termina en una
posición hacia arriba pero en principio
estaba en una posición ecuatorial y
ahora está en una posición axial así que
ahora que ya sabemos dónde poner los
grupos metilo vamos a dibujar las dos
con formaciones silla
así y recuerden que hay que tener
bastante cuidado a la hora de hacer
estos dibujos verdad
no es algo que se puede hacer de forma
tan sencilla digamos algo así este es un
ejemplo de cómo es un poco complicado
hacer los dibujos verdad entonces ahí
tenemos nuestro ciclohexano este va para
arriba este va para abajo arriba abajo
arriba
abajo verdad y luego otra vez tenemos
bueno tendríamos que empezar digamos
aquí hacia abajo
y luego hacia arriba y lo
hacia abajo y luego hacia arriba hacia
abajo
y arriba muy bien entonces aquí tenemos
nuestra primera conformación de tipo
silla y dijimos que en el primer carbono
y vamos a tener nuestro grupo metilo
hacia arriba verdad en una posición
axial y ahí lo tienen es justamente esta
primera conformación y en el segundo en
el segundo carbono y va también a estar
en una posición hacia arriba pero en
este caso tendría que ser ecuatorial
verdad entonces si nosotros queremos
pintar la otra con formación
esta esta doble flecha digamos y la otra
conformación silla pues será más o menos
contraria verdad entonces
tipo de d
configuración
y lo tienen muy bien entonces ahora
donde empezamos hacia arriba es acá
arriba abajo arriba abajo
arriba y abajo y luego empezamos hacia
arriba por ejemplo aquí abajo
arriba aquí abajo acá arriba aquí abajo
acá muy bien entonces ahora donde quedan
para la segunda conformación
estos grupos entonces para el primer
carbono para el primer carbono quedamos
que queda arriba pero en una posición
ecuatorial entonces sería este de aquí
mientras que para el segundo carbono
dijimos que queda en posición
axial hacia arriba verdad entonces aquí
tengo mi
h 3
así que tenemos ahí estos dos casos y la
pregunta es cuál de estas dos con
formaciones es la más estable y si
pensamos por ejemplo en el caso de la
izquierda tenemos un sustituye ente
axial de gmail o anotando tenemos un
sustituye ente axial un sustituye ente
axial mí y tenemos un sustituye ente
ecuatorial verdad vamos a dejarlo sólo
así en el segundo caso en el caso de la
derecha tenemos un sustituye ente axial
y un sustituye ente ecuatorial verdad
así que realmente ninguno de estos es
más estable que el otro ambos son con
formaciones
igualmente estables ok eso esto es
estamos pensando en el 612 dimetil
ciclohexano tienen exactamente la misma
el mismo nivel de energía ahora vamos a
hacer otro 12 dimetil ciclohexano
un poquito hacia abajo y vamos a empezar
otra vez con la estructura de puntos
pero ahora no vamos a dejar que se
encuentren del mismo lado es decir vamos
a partir de nuestro ciclohexano
ciclo
ciclohexano y en el primer carbono en
lugar de ir hacia arriba más bien va más
en el primer carbono va a ir hacia
arriba más bien lo tiene vamos a tener
nuestro primer grupo metilo nuestro
sustituye ente pero en el segundo ahora
en vez de que vaya en la digamos hacia
el mismo lado vamos a dejar que vaya al
lado contrario es decir va a estar
digamos no en dirección hacia nosotros
sino hacia el otro lado digamos del
papel o de la pantalla entonces a éste
justamente nuevamente se le conoce como
el 12 dimetil ciclohexano ciclo hexano
pero tiene una conformación distinta al
caso anterior verdad en el caso anterior
se le llamaba cis cuando estos dos
sustituye entes y van en la misma
dirección en este como van en dirección
contraria vamos a llamarle trans
trans 1/2 dimetil ciclohexano y la
verdad es que el trans 1/2 dimetil
ciclohexano es una molécula diferente al
612 dimetil ciclohexano no puedes rotar
un cis para convertirlo en un trans y
viceversa así que realmente son
distintas moléculas con distintas
propiedades y distintas conformaciones y
ya vamos a dibujar algunas con
formaciones silla para esta esta
molécula
vamos a poner estos y recuerden hay que
tener bastante cuidado verdad
cuidado más o menos este es un intento
de un dibujo de tipo silla ahí está uno
arriba y uno abajo uno arriba uno abajo
uno arriba uno abajo aquí ya pinte el de
abajo ahora va hacia arriba hacia abajo
hacia arriba hacia abajo y hacia arriba
muy bien esta es una conformación tipo
silla y decimos que en el primer carbono
tenemos un grupo metilo que va hacia
arriba en este caso pues sería de forma
axial verdad en el otro caso en el
segundo carbono digamos aquí está
nuestro segundo carbono decimos que va
hacia abajo va hacia abajo y en este
caso pues también va de forma axial aquí
tenemos dos 2
sustituyen test axiales vamos a ver qué
pasa digamos con la otra conformación
silla
si allá dibujamos digamos nuestro parece
como un relámpago verdad
digamos ahí está nuestro relámpago
ahí lo tienen entonces aquí va hacia
arriba hacia abajo arriba
arriba abajo y luego este va a ir hacia
arriba digamos aquí abajo arriba
arriba y abajo entonces si nosotros
tenemos nuestro primer carbono aquí aquí
está nuestro primer carbono decimos
también que va a quedar en la en la
misma dirección digamos hacia arriba
pero ya no de forma axial sino
ecuatorial mientras que en el segundo
carbono van a quedar también hacia abajo
pero como aquí en acción ahora aquí
queda ecuatorial también verdad queda
ecuatorial muy bien
entonces la cantidad de sustituyen test
que tenemos
aquí en realidad los dos sustituyen test
que tenemos son ecuatoriales verdad los
dos son ecuatoriales y lo que ya sabemos
es que siempre hay que buscar hay que
buscar que los grupos voluminosos se
encuentran en posición ecuatorial porque
eso disminuye el impedimento estético
así que realmente ocurre que el caso de
la derecha es el que es más estable
ahora vamos a hacer uno más ok vamos a
fijarnos en otra estructura de puntos ok
vamos a fijarnos en otra estructura de
puntos ahora vamos a pensar vamos a
pensar en esta conformación bueno
tenemos otro ciclohexano que ya está un
ciclo hexano y ahora vamos a pensar que
tenemos un grupo sustituye ente muy muy
voluminoso aquí o que entonces ponemos
digamos una cuña vamos a pensar que está
en dirección hacia nosotros un grupo
estilo esto es un ch 2
h 3 muy bien y vamos a pensar que en el
carbono 3 este sería el carbono 2
tenemos un grupo metilo pero en
dirección contraria a donde nos
encontramos nosotros muy bien
así que vamos a dibujar las
conformaciones y ya que podemos hacer de
esta de esta molécula y veamos si
podemos determinar la estabilidad de
esas con formaciones silla para esta
molécula muy bien entonces vamos a
dibujar la conformación silla una
conformación silla por la derecha aquí
perdón aquí del lado izquierdo
nuestro
nuestro relámpago yo creo que después de
varios ejemplos uno se empieza a volver
más hábil para dibujar esto verdad es
que en principio puede ser complicado
ahora vamos a poner aquí uno arriba uno
abajo uno arriba uno abajo uno arriba
uno abajo y luego tenemos uno abajo uno
arriba uno abajo uno arriba uno abajo
uno arriba muy bien entonces tenemos
esta conformación silla de una vez
ponemos la otra ok vamos a pintar la
otra con formación silla esto sería más
o menos así está nuestro relámpago
y ahí está y ahora ponemos uno arriba
uno abajo uno arriba uno abajo uno
arriba y uno abajo y ahora va a uno
abajo uno arriba uno abajo uno arriba
uno abajo y uno arriba muy bien entonces
si nos fijamos en el primer átomo de
carbono digamos aquí está nuestro primer
átomo de carbono eso nos dice que hacia
arriba y de forma axial tenemos el grupo
etilo ahí está el grupo de tilo mientras
que en el tercer carbono que ahora se
encuentra de este lado tenemos hacia
abajo y en este caso sería de forma
ecuatorial tenemos un grupo metilo vamos
a poner aquí el grupo metilo muy bien
del lado derecho que es lo que ocurre
del lado derecho en el primer carbono el
primer carbono corresponde a este
tenemos hacia arriba pero de forma
ecuatorial
el grupo estilo mientras que en el
tercer carbono ahora no de forma
ecuatorial sino de forma axial tenemos
un grupo metilo así que la pregunta es
cuál de estas dos con formaciones es la
más estable para esta molécula y si
pensamos en el ejemplo de la izquierda
tenemos un grupo estilo de forma axial y
un grupo metilo de forma ecuatorial el
ejemplo de la derecha tiene un grupo
metilo de forma axial y un grupo estilo
de forma ecuatorial y dado que el grupo
de tilo es mucho más voluminoso que el
grupo metilo yo más bien elegiría o más
bien nos gustaría más que el grupo
estilo se encontrara en la posición
ecuatorial así que esté del lado derecho
resulta ser la conformación más estable
ok de hecho podemos calcular la cantidad
de impedimento estético por ejemplo para
el lado izquierdo se sabe que el
impedimento se calcula como 48 kilos
jules por mol verdad y del lado derecho
tendríamos 7.6
los bulls por mol así que sabemos que
mientras más baja sea la cantidad de
energía de energía potencial o bueno en
este caso de impedimento estético mucho
más estable resulta ser la molécula
así que la conformación de la derecha es
mucho más estable que la conformación de
la izquierda para este ciclo hexano y
sustituido